hey i don't see sighs
all i see is i see what's inside is that
what it is dude yeah man that's what it
is you just see a man's character i'm
sorry not even a man's character a
person persons when i talk about people
then i say folks and it's f-o-l-x
yeah it's a new thing dude okay because
i don't know what you are and i'm not
going to put a label on you you're not
going to assume even though i want to
separate you by your past depression and
by your privilege but i don't want to do
that otherwise
but we got to treat each other as
individuals
except we still have to do an
intersectionality and see where you
stand in the pantheon of suffering sure
if you're a woman that's that's if
you're a white woman you're a head of a
black woman who's ahead of a
a black woman who's coming in hot today
dude you know what you know what you do
see though you see shoes
you see these you got the yeah the love
spectrum shoes on no these are low
spectrum
why are they so worn out these are two
boots they're supposed aren't those the
ones that are supposed to be worn
did i buy those yeah when you buy when
you buy expensive those were for like
your 45th birthday they were something
like that right they were
you keep shoes huh but look at how they
jesus
let's be honest is anyone like [ __ ] dude
they missed the taboo
i need to see those thanks chen
they [ __ ] do and they feel better on
your feet i just don't really wear a ton
of boots when i go to new york i'll wear
boots yeah but it's just too much of a
hassle yeah it's it's a buckle it's a
lace
it's exactly like taking a shotgun
as shoes they're not i can't remember
last time i wore boots although there's
something there was always something
about
you know dressing
in an uncomfortable way so so back in
the day you were especially if you were
an aristocrat or you were a professor or
whatever the [ __ ] stupid
yeah you wore a three-piece suit even
like this is i like [ __ ] i don't dude
and you were bespoke you wore your shoes
were made for you that you polished your
shoes
your tie probably cost 200 300 400
there was losers where is this
i mean in england in new york you were a
banker if you were um economist there
was a uniform man in new york
you didn't go to the bank without
without even new york now it's still
like obviously there's slobs out there
but there's also like for the most part
you don't see a lot of people in sweats
there was a form of a very la thing yes
your shoes were not supposed to be
comfortable i don't let my son walk out
in sweats i walk out with sweats i know
you you never heard a man you never
heard a man say things like well i can
wear these shoes all day they're super
comfortable that that wasn't a thing
yeah your shoes had a had a leather sole
that you laced them up
everything was difficult but there's
something dope about it if you have some
nice boots some nice jeans just a plain
tee like that's a dope ass outfit change
the way you are too yeah so that with
acting they used to always say one of
the best actors i've ever worked with
and known said the minute i got the
shoes the minute i knew what kind of
shoes that character had i mean this
gets kooky but it's true
it does change you you will negotiate
the world differently if you're in
moccasins
versus really expensive bespoke dress
shoes that makes sense but that's all
yeah you feel different but even with
street wear like the fashion side of it
like there's like joggers and stuff you
can wear yeah yeah i saw a guy
in manhattan beach running barefoot he
was jogging barefoot that's a thing use
jogging barefoot they take a barefoot
clear like like
in the sand up a lot of things like oh
yeah well you get into some glass well
they're like it's the way the caveman
right i get that i get that and then
they invented shoes yeah an antibiotic
for a reason yeah and phones you know
things well he does it on the on the
concrete not the sand
i've seen the concrete yeah he was
everywhere he was on the street well
have you ever wore those uh the vibrams
the [ __ ] like they're like basically
like rogan tried it a couple times
[ __ ]
so all the vagina dries up within a
20 mile radius between those and hugs
yeah i used to i wore them for a little
bit i walked around in my foot socks
they're foot socks right yeah they're
aqua socks yeah you're a kid and
meanwhile you want dance reach with your
toes showing yeah yeah you got a pair of
uggs
uh slippers oh slippers around the house
i got i got uggs they're nice they're
made of uh
my thing you know what they're for yeah
they're they're uh they got popular
because a pair of salt and but they're
originally designed in australia for
when they got the ocean with the sand so
yeah oh wow yeah it's like that sheep
well i love that sheep wool i like
ultimately what do i want to do i want
to always be in wool i always be in fur
ultimately it is it's a little cold like
i'd like americans yeah i'd like to
always have some fur against my body
dude we're fur coats and [ __ ] i might
start
well hey although i don't know well you
know so i retract that statement
the inuit you would see they were
talking about this guy and how he
dressed so the british explorers when
they would go to the arctic they would
get frozen in for the winter yeah they'd
have all their supplies in the boat
they'd get frozen in and then they would
do their exploration to see if there
were any routes trade routes they could
take would it be now that's a great time
see what happens is
sometimes it doesn't fall out and you
run out of food you gotta eat your buddy
you gotta start eating your butt you're
eating your friends and it's good time
too because the gangrene that's awesome
when you get when you're cold all the
time and you're well they gotta start
lopping [ __ ] off there's a famous story
about the the the
leader of the one of the expeditions
those brits were hard
hard you never complained ever that was
the people think about what they are oh
my gosh one island tomorrow island what
the [ __ ] oh england
and there we go and he said this he
literally said this in the fashion of
the the old english aristocracy he's got
frostbite
they're all starving to death and he
went he went
i'm going for a walk and i may be some
time
and he just and they just said the
geyser fight said we just saw him
stroll off into the blizzard and he just
never was never [ __ ] good
tell a man he didn't want to die in
front of us it was unsightly and
inconveniencing
that boss what a boss to die that way i
i'm going for a walk and i may be some
time i would not go there
we gotta huddle up now now how about
this
the next exhibition [ __ ] the cabin or
the one of the guys they were like you
know what
oh and by the way the inuit saw them but
when the inuit saw them the what you'd
call eskimos they they saw them
lug in
body parts that they were eating and
they were like these white people are
gross let's get the [ __ ] away from them
and ran away no we do whatever it takes
that's correct
now they they pretty much perished
and it's not dodgy
i was gonna say now
now the next exhibition the [ __ ] uh
the guy goes you know what here's what
we're gonna do
uh we're gonna go right to the first
inuit village and trade them some [ __ ]
and ask them what the secrets are
because how to survive here's the
biggest problem what do you think the
biggest problem is in that environment
besides food
it's like warm
yeah that too but what what is the what
yeah how do you find
in icebergs you have to boil it well no
it's all salt water so where's the fresh
water
those icebergs ain't
no they're salt where do we find the the
fresh water
there's a color you got to go deep and
you got to find the color you have to
tell there's a color to certain ice
that's that's fresh water versus the
others
i see that [ __ ] that's how they live bro
they can find they'll catch you a seal
and by the way the first thing the
inuits did is they go okay here you go
guys hey
your wool very cool your leather very
cool that's great your kung fu no good
for this environment because it's going
to get down to 50 below so what we're
going to do is you're going to collect a
whole bunch of we'll teach you how to
make an igloo collect a whole bunch of
driftwood so you can burn it and oh by
the way you also have to burn we're
going to teach you how to render seal
and whale fat so you're going to do that
that's fuel and take all your clothes
off and we're going to sell you
some some caribou and seal clothes and
then one white guy went thank you let's
shoot
what the [ __ ]
the guy said he was wearing that one of
the guys was wearing polar bear
underwear basically polar bear that is
lit that's horrible yeah what that looks
like now they kill a polar bear how the
[ __ ] do you kill a polar bear i guess
they would take
polar bear bone as super hard
so they would actually get a polar bear
bone spear and i guess the polar bears
there are sometimes when the polar bears
are sleeping or semi hibernating and
they would find where those [ __ ]
polar bears are turning their sleep stab
them right through the [ __ ] right is
that a pretty god that works first yeah
no that's a polar bear [ __ ] up you're
killing the polar bear with his boy's
bones
then you eat it and then you take the
fur and please don't eat the liver
because he'll die but you also gotta
cook it well done too much what
because you got trigonosis right
actually not polar bears oh really no
because in polar bear land they kill
living animals
and oh
and because of the
carcasses yeah and because the cold that
[ __ ] doesn't rot oh interesting yeah so
when the inuit had um when they have uh
they would have like wolf wool mittens
my buddy went in uh sam sheridan he went
and lived with them and they all have
wool mittens they had these wool uh i'm
not woman's wolf wolf
fur mittens
but when you're in the cold you don't
have to you don't have to treat the
leather you can kind of just the leather
just stays what it is it's so [ __ ]
weird man that's a hard one
yeah and they also have they've also
evolved so they their body their blood
circulates if you and i were there we'd
all our hands and feet would just fall
off yeah because it's not usually
because your body the blood goes to your
torso the core not with them
not without it just circulates
cbd
cbd is the way for me apparently
now tell me if i have anxiety yeah i got
pain somewhere yeah cbd somehow has
stressful pain yeah dude so explain but
you need premium cbd that will help keep
your head clear and feel your best you
need hassle free delivered right to your
door that's where feels comes in so it
helps with stress anxiety pain
sleeplessness how's all that dude that
has all that is there a hangover yep and
feels is a better way to feel better all
right few simple drops under that old
dry tongue of yours like a bird you drop
under your tongue and automatically
you're feeling better dude and then also
feels offers free cbd hotline to help
you guide you along your cbd journey man
all right you can join the uh monthly
membership with feels f-e-a-l-s yep
you'll save money on every order you can
pause or cancel anytime start feeling
better with feels become a member today
by going to feels f e a l s dot com
slash fighter you get fifty percent off
your first order and free shipping no
hangover that's feels f e a l s
dot com slash fighter to become a member
and get fifty percent
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping fields.com
fighter b it's the holiday season and
man it's a great time but if you're an
online store it's the craziest time you
got to get your orders out fast you got
to have a trustworthy shipper that's
where ship station comes in if you sell
anything online i don't need to tell you
that shipping can be contoured
frustrating to phil growing list of
stressed out customers checking in twice
a day wondering whether or not those
last minute gifts will arrive on time
this is where ships ship stations and
they work with all major carriers all
right including fedex usps ups we got it
all man all right no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that freaking
good you sell anything online ship
station makes it way easier make this
holiday season a little brighter with
ship station use the code fighter to get
a 60-day free trial 60 days yeah dude
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone top of the page enter the
code fighter ship station make ship
happen
did you notice uh he's in green today
mix it up yeah you mix it up it's a
little weathered but that's apparently
no that's a solid green for you solid
green yes green's the color of geniuses
you know that i did not know that yep i
like your aaron rodgers thank you sir
i'm a fan
you just you just get this what's his
suspension
um
i think he's back next they lost right
yeah which is good for him yeah he's
like yeah [ __ ] that's quarterbacking
fighters
oh yeah yeah love the backup this is not
expected
and it's funny to me that if you turn to
espn or fox
not so much fox but really espn they're
all [ __ ] on aaron rodgers and then
you know odell beckham got cut from the
browns and he's looking for a new home
obviously with aaron rodgers you know
he's such a beast he'd be a perfect fit
but the commentators on espn are like no
it's not going to work out if he were to
go to green so they're trying to sway
you know the the public from hit you
know campaigning for odell beckham to go
to green bay yeah because if you went
there they'd be sick they'd be super
is still a bad [ __ ] good you
know where's the end now the browns no
you got cut oh yeah just got caught
sir antonio brown doing over at he's all
right he was hurt but he played last
week he's good
but i just think it's funny at the media
because of his stance on vaccines is
trying to shame them of course they are
dude
i mean you know
it's just it's weird right it's like
imagine being mad at a guy for that
and the thing is like
he [ __ ] uh he could have been up like
people were like well he should have
been up front at the jump
yeah i get it and and how has society
treated people who were up front are
they really nice to them how do they
treat kyrie irving are they really nice
to a guy who
had just and his here's the thing you
know him and rogan are close he spoke to
rogan before all this and he's going to
kill him
he's close with rogers yeah oh wow yeah
rogan's the one who sent them to his
doctor that's why he oh i didn't know
that's better
oh weird it's like rogan knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing
so obviously he's associated with rogan
the left comes after him but
with uh aaron rodgers it's not he's not
anti-vaccine he's allergic to two
substances in the vaccine if you go on
the cdc website in red in all capital
letters it says if you're allergic to
these properties which he is two out of
the four do not take the vaccine
okay now if you would have came out up
front it again i still think people
would have [ __ ] all over them but he
also he has coveted right he has goals
so he's got the communities
we also know scientifically that the
vaccine loses its effective efficacy
over over a period of time and
dramatically apparently that's why i
just think that's weird the way they
treat him and if your argument's like
well he should been up front at the
start yeah and how has society treated
people who were up front and not things
i'm not antibiotic vaccine at all i'm
vaccinated yeah i'm not here and i have
kobe yep so suck this cover dick you
know what i'm saying so for him it's
like oh why wouldn't he be open about it
oh because you guys
it's not a warm welcome if you're if you
say anything about the vaccine even if
he's allergic to it oh [ __ ] but you
know yeah like you you guys like there's
nothing he can say
there's a reason why he didn't feel safe
to come out and go hey i i don't feel
comfortable doing this it's a very it's
a very divisive it's insane it's a very
divisive toxic
you know i heard more [ __ ] on the travis
scott stuff
so uh you know how like eight people
died he's had crazy [ __ ] happen before
but apparently and this is a theory
coming from the houston police
department there was a crazy guy
stabbing people with fentanyl what the
[ __ ] killing them what now they don't
know the conspiracy here so hang tight
they don't know if that's just a
conspiracy the houston police is running
with so they take pressure and they'll
blame them because they're supposed to
be their security yeah so them saying
there's a madman who you know was was
you know giving people fentanyl and
killing people so they there's a lot of
there's a lot of these theories that got
like on conspiracy social club sam and i
got into it this isn't what about this
this isn't one of those things no they
have nothing but but i feel like a lot
of people are like a lot of people like
[ __ ] uh he's a satanist i'm like god
damn it can you please already yeah just
cause he had anyone whose success was a
satanist
yes he's part of the skull well dude he
did a show where there was fire coming
up from the ground oh wow
so did elton john me and kevin
look at this
one there was injecting people with
drugs
secured off right the festival was
pricked in the neck with a needle by an
unknown person he said the security
officer went unconscious then was
treated and revived with narcan the
medical analysis rate used for treatment
known to a suspected opiate overdose
this is all 37 years old this is still
hearsay right so yeah um
well that's a guy at the event saying i
was pranked in the [ __ ] net yeah with
opiates
so but the houston police department's
running with this like yeah that's what
happened yeah
oh people got crushed
yeah i wonder what they're gonna do with
him right because that's and then now
obviously if you do this the haters can
come out and they're digging up all his
old post of
you know like showing kids who were
passed out going you know
this guy's earned it or like what is
this this kid this is from previous this
is years ago this is you know that's
march 2015 that's july 2014. look what
that kid's not got knocked out at his
concert look to the kid that didn't
survive the rodeo you're a hero in my
book so he like he promotes that
craziness yeah he praised them being
their kids are actually dead no no
they're not they're just [ __ ] up yeah
[ __ ] up from his thing
but i mean i mean i know most people
know what they're saying for when they
attract scout concerts right i don't
think anybody expects to die i don't
think travis scott
this is this is him using
marketing tactics this is not a guy who
wants people to die of course not
no
you know i mean
and i don't think anything happens to
him i don't either i think live nation
is going to be in a little bit of
trouble in the houston police department
and especially if we find out there's a
guy [ __ ] stabbing people in the neck
and [ __ ] with that yeah i think the only
thing travis scott has to worry about is
people uh pulling him from different
festivals because so far he got pulled
from one in vegas there well he better
put posters he didn't he didn't get
pulled he backed out of that oh god that
that's the good thing the big one's
gonna be
coachella because he supposed to
headline coachella yeah and they're like
there's four thousand signatures and
pulling from coachella four thousand if
he goes to his fans go hey sign this
thing so i go to coachella there's gonna
be millions of yeah
four thousand well he uh four thousand
that don't want him do it no get out of
here listen fifty five hundred now he'll
he'll um fifty five hundred in
comparison
you better get ten dollars you better
get ten million yeah why why do you
think he's so popular what is it about
him his style like his style like his
type of music is completely different
than everybody else
yeah he's like a combination he's like a
game he was like a game changer in his
yeah he was just he was just different
yeah he's super talented he's not there
for no reason yeah he's a talent he
attracts like the younger generation
drake and kanye like everybody [ __ ]
them everybody andre three thousand yeah
he's really talented super talented so
so the documentary on him
yeah he's super yeah yeah they have the
documentary yeah the documentary on him
on netflix you can't watch that not like
the guy like they have a clip on there
when he first started like 2m13 and he's
at what was known as astroworld which
was a music all this stuff called
astroworld was an amusement park when
his kid growing up poor he always wanted
to go to and it was his favorite place
to go to and it got you know they
financially couldn't maintain the
property so they lost it so it's not
open anymore so he revived astroworld
and that's his branding now astroworld
so they have a thing where he's at
astroworld before it shut down he's
doing a concert there and there's in the
crowd maybe 12 people nobody knows who
he is and he's going hard in the paint
you know to it too i've worked with just
over my 25 years in hollywood having
worked with
famous rappers you know like whether
it's ice cube or you know whoever it is
or iced tea or who i don't know yeah a
lot of them had a hard like this is for
me for the 90s they had a hard kind of
exterior and by the way they came from
at the time it was pretty rough and it
was over south central and so but
a person to a rapper and then i heard
then i've had conversations with people
work with people like the game nas
to a person they they always were
insanely professional
insanely disciplined and absolutely the
opposite of any kind of like
nobody's saying that about you yeah
everyone knows yeah he's pretty
disciplined yeah well i'm just saying
he's you you'd get there and you'd be
like the guy could have a conversation
with you about pretty much everything
it's like yeah it's never a mistake it's
never an accident that somebody's that
successful and not impressive now in his
cloud with jordan
i mean the hottest shoe he i mean he's
been killing it with the mcdonald's
thing too yes mcdonald's collab did the
thing with uh what was that video's baby
mama's kylie jenner fortnight yeah yeah
crushes it yeah he made a during the
play my son wanted it my son wanted to
go to the travis concert in the
fortnight uh yeah yeah nuts
they pulled him from the game after uh
i'm pretty sure they pulled him from the
game after all this really tell him
about the idea i had for it for us
what you got an idea no i don't know i
i'm not entertaining this hey i don't
want i like i love you i'm gonna get
some ideas all right i'm gonna pitch you
the idea [ __ ] it all right lay it on me
brandon don't be shitty i remember two
weeks ago it was brandon toads okay
hundreds of thousands of dollars we
actually made some money on it yeah we
actually made money all right
okay so so ready so
um so
travis scott hella concert in the
fortnight space uh-huh how come
how come we don't own the first meta
comedy club
where you can [ __ ] digital comedy club
yeah where you go you can sign up
anywhere in the world you're in hold on
hey do you mind
we have our own comedy club you
virtually can attend
anyone we can do a we could do a [ __ ]
comedy night and anywhere you are in the
world you pay five bucks to to be
in our comedy club our medic comedy club
what
why
you're welcome guys that was already
happening during the pandu because yeah
[Applause]
no i'm thinking about this so if we had
like a green screen so you have a green
screen you'd get up and you do your
stand-up you could actually have a live
show but it's a green screen i'm about
to show you guys a picture i watched
like i know we've done that he does so
now you you didn't have to instead of
zoom you you actually you you virtually
enter the room you can virtually get
your room but still you're not in person
and you're in a con you're you're there
and you're actually you can see people
next to you
and now you're actually watching
comments it's a zoom but you know is
that the future though i don't think so
live comments yeah i guarantee if you
ask any of those kids that attended that
fortnight concert would you rather be in
person yeah or have the headset
no
isn't that something they would do
without being see that's totally
different that's not what i'm talking
about no brian also that only worked
because it was the pandemic
he wouldn't have done that if it wasn't
no but
because i remember exactly where i was
when i first heard about the first one
but wait if you can't go to a concert
right say you're in i don't know your
[ __ ] wherever it is yeah and you
have your virtual goggles and you're
sitting down in a theater in a digital
theater like go to have you seen mark
zuckerberg's [ __ ] metaverse
go go show that for a second watch this
so now you're so now you're actually in
a theater watching comedy next to people
but you're not though you're right
but it's better than
something i i just so we look like
characters yeah yes like you have you
seen what they're able to do now watch
this metaverse [ __ ] you wanna watch the
trailer of it or yeah watch it it's
[ __ ] it's it's that [ __ ] looks
[ __ ] stupid yeah but it's it's crazy
watch how people are going to be taking
meetings now
it's it's nuts it's nuts see i'm not
talking about digital comedy i'm talking
about
like literally that's digital so what we
have so so this is all fake behind
company brand to encompass everything
that we do gotta get a weird [ __ ]
reflection why because he looks like a
robot we hope to build how many bodies
our company is now
meta now you're in here
you're you're this is this is you can
create any room you want imagine
you put on your glasses or headset and
you're instantly in your home space you
can choose whatever you want to do
whatever you want hey
hey look i'm telling you right now look
at me yeah i know that's the future yeah
we get it
listen look at me
now give me let me let me let me pitch
you now now do you have the funding to
build an entire meta universe
it's so easy so wait people would think
that they're in the theater watching us
is what you're saying dude
i [ __ ] what instead why don't you
just go to those markets we're gonna do
it live bro but are there we want to
reach the world
five bucks
you come into the [ __ ] i don't know
what we call it
we have our meta theater the meta club
dude the meta club listen yeah because
martin luther is not
copyrighting
it's the first [ __ ] comedy club that
we we create our own first comedy club
you can put on your glasses you get in
the cup you take your seat and you watch
us get up on stage and do stand up i'm
just telling you that is going to happen
so we're only performing for them
there's no one there's no idea it's pay
to be in the [ __ ] audience you have
to pay you have to pay five dollars to
put your [ __ ] glasses on and wherever
you are in the world you can come and
watch us do our special but hey dude
now first come on
nope somebody no
yes
dude you admit what's wrong with his eye
i know he's an average what's on your
what's all over your arms i had those
burned off this
you have more burned off well i told you
he's gonna do more no that was the same
day and and that was the same day jack
oh and she went oh she went let me do
the whole she goes let me see and of
course all right so she's just gonna
throw them off yep but it's all going
away yeah it's just scabs yeah yeah it's
going to be nothing to get more done no
i won't gent it no i won't i don't have
stuff done yeah you do excuse me imagine
if i had like botox in my face that's
only a matter of time dad no i'm not
getting botox uh
no i'm sure people are gonna be doing it
but isn't this weird how everything
behind them is fake not at all
i mean
that's what we're gonna be doing dude
you're going to be in the theater hey
we're going to be doing it
huh
you're going to be dead
my time this is like this is one year
away
get the work done now 15 years it's
going to be it's going to be long i'll
tell you what how about this how about
this ready seven how about this yeah i
built i'm gonna have it built okay i'm
gonna have it built oh yeah and we're
gonna be the first comics the three of
us
to do a show someone's gonna do it
no they're not you should save this up
here dude
yeah no it's great hey i said it first
it's not original yeah you said it first
so you know i it is original i'm an
original thinker see now you're you're
kind of coming over to my
we'll have a crowd you can have a crowd
as well how are we going to have a crowd
just like just like get like seats and
stuff like that well i've done that but
i was like
why not where are you at this weekend
i'm glad you asked off the hook comedy
there you go
and i linked you up with my boy yes so
you're naples why not just broadcast it
on youtube yeah you're on stage
because you're not in the theater so so
with with this with youtube you're
watching it on your screen if you have
your glasses with metaverse you're
actually in this yeah it's a fake but
it's a fake but you feel like you're in
there like people like dude
i'm just telling you as this technology
oh no that's gonna be the future for
sure yeah but i think it's it i think
what happens is you will be able to
reach everyone you want and so if
somebody can't afford how do you do a
tour huh you don't you can't tour that
you wouldn't be able to tour of course
you can tour you can also tour i'm just
saying you could hold these these sort
of like
shows if you wanted for the world so
anybody anywhere who's a fan of yours
but why wouldn't you just go over there
in person like yeah like africa
you can also do that but i mean think
about the difference if you if you
wanted to reach a bunch of people say
it's a half hour instead of doing a
special
you can just say this this special is
now you can come to my special you can
watch it in the better verse yeah in in
my metaphor burn the material yeah
and i don't know if you have to burn the
material because what happens is you can
only see it if you paid that five
dollars so one and then it goes away
yeah one of the cool things you can't
screen grab it you can't record it the
thing about the metaverse is you have to
pay to be in it so now you're you're
doing literally a show for only people
who are willing to attend
i i think
yeah it's so crazy man i miss the way
it's going i guess
i don't like that you're i know you're
trying to do this you're
he's made money he goes um
he goes i like the guys who actually
made money at it and who you know done
very well and he said it's all trash
bitcoin that's fine ethereum yeah
everything else is just [ __ ]
horseshoe yeah i don't understand it
i mean well you're not going to make it
well anytime you make money on like
dogecoin that's like that's like trading
it's like nfts
it's like people decide that oh this is
all can you explain it to me bro i'm
like oh my god
the listener's like
well you can create you can create fake
demand you create whatever you want
with uh with [ __ ] uh dope chipotle
paintings you could recreate anything
yeah
and a bunch of brokers
and they would just buy
the brokers were like they would buy the
paintings
jack the price up
and then sell them on the open market
bank ski too like i mean that's a lot
they do that with a lot of things not
just yeah yeah price demand yeah they do
it with shoes paintings all sorts of
cars oh yeah yeah especially cars yeah
all right guys metaverse coming to you
what do you want to call our virtual
theater
i mean we need facebook to kind of
no get all the kinks out it's all diy
it's true yeah we need to get all the
kinks out and then everyone's hey
everybody make sure you buy the goggles
to attend which are gonna be how much a
thousand no way cheaper not a chance the
first round of them i mean i don't know
how expensive those goggles would be hey
you're hitting me with all these details
yeah so right now it's just for like
meetings and to hang out with friends
you know right this year i really do
think i'm i'm kidding obviously i'm not
but i don't know it's definitely a
future it's the future i think it's
going to be interesting which will be
my dad doesn't have an office they
should all do it from home not weird he
was like literally he was like in june
we got rid of the up and he's been in
office for 30 years he's like we don't
have an office anymore yeah
all that space but but he
he thought about a long time ago he
tried it with his first uh business that
he had and silicon valley did this years
ago before this pandemics because so
expensive in silicon valley so like oh
let's just have people call in and work
from home and
the the work load like yeah people just
tailor up you need to kind of i think
human interaction
yeah there's nothing like being there i
don't know
that's why we can't perform
movies like movie theater going feels am
i wrong oh 100 percent dead yeah like
these i don't know movie no i went to
the other day tactic though right it's
not as fun but it's coming back for sure
yeah but do they have premieres like
because oh yeah they had a premiere the
other night for the the gucci movie with
like netflix with certain these movies
these netflix
yeah so you have this big they never do
shows up on your tv and you're like but
yeah i love that [ __ ] yeah oh cat i
finished uh season three of you how'd
you like it
it's good yeah it was good really good
he was good yeah he was really good
did you like the ending or no yeah i dug
it now narcos season was it season three
i think three yeah it's three season
three the narcos mexico yeah that's
where the show runner uh was murdered
you think i'm gonna go scouting uh
cineloa whatever
i'm gonna go scout well the problem is
is cartel everywhere and they show them
the face so bad dude what yep
i mean yeah this was just recent well
it's it's uh season three well one of
the things you you you realize about
like any time you have a criminal
organizations
is that it's run very tight but
a lot of times like with them with the
mafia and stuff there would always be a
couple of serial killers that would
sneak in as they hit men and they [ __ ]
things up they just [ __ ] they're not
professional no they just kill
whoever they're like yeah you know roy
demayo same thing like that's why they
killed him because they were like they
found it he was just
killing dudes there was like the joe
joe pesci character and goodfellas like
dude he's out of control yeah yeah well
roy's killing romero had he those are
all baseball he was a big earner and the
[ __ ] guy
says to sammy the boy he goes i got 200
bodies under my belt and they go tonight
who's giving you these orders he goes
now i just keep my guys sharp yeah when
there's a guy who's drunk at the bar you
know it was like what yeah
we got to kill this [ __ ] guy he's
liability i mean he's a serial killer
what happened to joe pesci's character
in good fellas
in casino just out of hand i just beat
him brother
[Music]
was a brutal scene where they beat his
brother and they bury him alive yeah and
you know it's not since 1995. what's his
name friend a friend says he for a mike
friends whatever his name he was a boss
and he said the guys that were crazy
like that that did all that crazy [ __ ]
they met pretty horrible deaths
themselves of course yeah they they just
are those guys never lasted they were
just maniacs oh cat uh real quick back
there you were the only ones who care
about uh yeah what's up you know it
wasn't filmed in norcal it's filmed in
encino oh yeah i don't imagine they did
anything in north carolina no i looked
it up because you just the neighborhood
looks dope
no keep regurgitating the same of the
bull stories
because no it looks like though no you
gotta see the
show i thought it was dope yeah but then
you look it up and that's not a real
it's not real city it's that particular
city is not real but they're based off
of a lot of suburbs it like closer to
san francisco it's really nice
the bay area is
beautiful i was watching that and it
gave me flashbacks i was talking to
steve oh there's really nothing like
that yeah yeah oh yeah
i was looking at that counter because i
looked it up yeah i see i've always
wanted to drive through that mirror you
would love it so is this is
everything's nor cal and then i looked
it up on like god damn it's nice where
is that and it was like it's actually
not a real city it was filmed mainly the
location was in ceno i'm like oh i know
some of those [ __ ] treasures county
is like [ __ ] beautiful big boy big
boy
those kind of big big damn but also it's
like it looks like the shire it's like
have you ever i looked at land up there
dude the house is like 30 40 million
stupid it hurts your feelings yeah oh
yeah perfectly like all right well and
then you just take a little drive up to
napa valley and grab yourself some some
lunch you know i mean [ __ ]
yeah wait isn't it where mark's from
marin candice he wasn't either yeah he's
from the bay area who who was mark was
the wrestling champion
i'm telling you go to any bay area town
next to san francisco the suburbs you'd
fall in love i know you'd love it it's
right next to the bay if you like the
weather kind of chilly but not like cold
cold it's great is the area where that
full house houses uh that's in san
francisco that's straight up san
francisco is that super nice uh that
area is not really that nice i wouldn't
say living in san francisco is nice
living in the suburbs on the outskirts
you don't want to be downtown oh gotta
go well that's awesome they've ruined
the city yeah
no hell no no down to the left
he lives in sacramento right i think
you'd also love palo alto so he had a
helmet
sick he had a home here
oh he had a 6 million he hadn't noised
me look at him dude he popped back up
his face isn't [ __ ] half melted
unfortunately
i don't want him to die i just wanted
half his he just wanted his face to just
he was like i was with my kids oh that's
that's convenient
you get the booster and go missing for
two weeks
yeah
and it's replacing literally said
they popped up we still haven't really
seen him it's very interesting yeah very
he might be a cyborg
he's right there in the background
they said that looks like
i love some of the [ __ ] awesome
conspiracy theorists
oh what are they like you know but you
know bob died in 2017. oh god you know
he's not he's a cyborg you're not a
robot well that's a [ __ ] does sam say
that why is the robot stuttering
they're all kind of the best
have you ever invited the the duchess of
whatever in england uh who married uh uh
prince philip i think remember the guy
yeah was princess diana's husband yeah
he got remarried right uh
the duchess of whatever windsor yeah
dude she met she met with biden have you
heard what she's been saying apparently
you know like my uncle when he was 70
would just rip farts apparently biden
ripped the longest loudest fart that's
all she can talk about
yeah he just ripped the longest fart
that's that's that's great i i feel bad
it's not my friend long fart during chat
i love when old guys don't give a [ __ ]
just let it rip you're ready look at him
um just farted right there farting hard
goddamn yeah that must be nice when you
get that age just let it rip dude you've
seen larry king just fart on air middle
of the [ __ ] interview there's like a
combination there's like a convolution
yeah
that doesn't matter crap
um yeah there's another conspiracy where
there's like they've decided that
everybody's moving to florida all the
conservatives are moving forward all the
people that believe in freedom and all
that and
there are a lot of hurricanes there and
ultimately they're all gonna die oh
the sales the state taxes no no dude no
no well they're doing that on purpose
desantis is actually getting there oh
god you can get them there that makes
sense you get them all in one area
then kill a tidal wave that kills
everyone so then everything's blue
because all the red is going to be dead
red's dead yeah we got to kill the right
makes sense so that that makes sense
damn yeah long and loud i wish someone
got he's old though i don't like making
fun of a guy for being old yeah you
gotta give him a little [ __ ] though you
know yeah
i mean he just farts like that colin
harris's uh approval rating is it 28
sorry no one [ __ ] with her it's at 28
percent
younger than biden and donald seems all
different three you know like he's like
biden's had a hard and hard he had a
heart he had a lot of trash in his life
i mean his wife died his family died
two of his daughters died his wife died
and then and then his son beau his
oldest son he was very close to died of
a brain tumor and then his son the other
son almost died another son is a drug
addict he's not a hard go man he's had a
hard gun
i think baden's actually really a good
person i think he's a good guy everybody
says that he's i don't i just don't
think he's that smart personally i i
think he's a smart guy he's just old
dude yeah you just put a [ __ ] old man
and yes the the most important position
he was always very much he was always
fairly moderate like an old-school
democrat
and and it seems that he's been he's
been essentially taken over by the far
left agenda the the super it's not even
his call like he has a team pushing the
agenda and he's like oh okay yeah and he
just kind of like okay old [ __ ] sign
this is like whatever that's what it
feels like yeah and they fart
whatever
and he just went like this i just saw
him go
and he had a coat he just put it in here
and then he looked over and he goes like
that and i'm just standing there like
that he just went
yeah like when you're that old yeah what
am i going to do turn you in yeah no
give him some candy
listen insurance for your home your car
it's a b expensive bro yeah that's where
the zebra saves people an average of 922
bucks a year on home and auto combined
what do they do here they focus on
details so you don't have to bro save
time and money in minutes compare quotes
for free at the zebra.com fighter that's
the zebra.com they read all the uh fine
print for yeah get you the best price
922
a year that's what i said save on
average on home and auto insurance
combined the zebra.com
if you want nutrition if you want
fitness where is she gonna go dude if
dude if you want supplements you want
the best though you want if you want you
want the best you want things for your
brain you want things for your sleep for
your body for your digestive health be
thick healthy dude you might want daily
support sometimes you need a little
daily support you got krill oil you got
some joints about some coffee we talking
about on it if you listen to this
podcast for the last eight freaking
years every single episode is brought to
you by
slash fighter onyx.com off we're talking
protein powders protein bars protein
bites fat butters elk bars warrior bars
we got fitness gear for your thick ass
kettlebells on it demand workouts home
fitness programs battle ropes we got it
all man they're up on the latest science
and they bring you the hands down best
supplements you can buy you can trust
them on it.com slash fighter temps off
the entire damn site
there we go
portugal just passed a law making it
illegal for bosses to text their
employees
uh after work hours because a lot of
people
in portugal
[Laughter]
this is not a start you know this is a
nine to five microsoft it's never like
lately
oh i'll text that's i take this mic at
two a.m i'll take that's a dumb law
because [ __ ] comes up and you gotta take
care of it well it's also because uh a
bunch of people in portugal and a lot of
companies have switched to moving uh all
their offices to their homes like you
said yeah and so a lot of people are not
finding a great work-life balance since
they're at home a lot of their
businesses will text them throughout the
day and they feel like they have to work
after hours they don't have a lot of
time with their kids so they pass this
law making it so if your boss texts you
or tries to reach out to you after work
hours they get fined
yeah
isn't this
taking down the carbon footprint of
cities when people aren't driving as
much
i would imagine right yeah i think so i
mean it helps yeah another part of this
law is that employers are going to
have to pay extra for the electricity
and internet of their employees trapped
at home twenty-four somebody talks about
that but you know dude like you want to
escape a little bit yeah i think so i
love my family but dude it's not every
now and i'm like all right see you later
yeah gotta see y'all
yeah i need to not talk for [ __ ] 20
minutes can i do that oh yeah
oh yeah when i was living in downtown i
noticed it too the smog was crazy but
then when the pandemic hit like
especially when i was in the heart of
downtown it just looked clear i could
see like you know hills and stuff like
that so it made a big difference for
sure
gave the what'd they say gave gave the
earth a little break
did they give it a breather i was
getting here in 12 minutes to santa
monica that was awesome yeah the flying
is awesome the thing about it
is that like you have to ask yourself
and really this is an honest question
i believe maybe the globe is warming 100
i don't know i'm not a scientist now i'm
inclined to believe that yeah do you
think that passing laws
and having low flush toilets
and stuff like that can actually cool
the planet i think it's like i'm just
like one percent do you think it's the
united states the problem or do you
think it's developing countries like
china and india that are the uh the most
egregious violence that we can't do
anything yeah no matter what north
america because they don't follow the
rules china you ever do china get sick
out there from the pollution come on you
ever seen the smog out there yeah you're
to your point india
so i i think even if north america like
let's say we just locked it down no
carbon footprint it did really good yeah
is it really doing anything i remember
over the indian ocean literally over the
indian ocean they saw
little cloud there was a smog cloud over
the indian ocean now
they're like well how big is it we
should measure it
it was the size of the continental
united states sir
small clouds so you know if you're going
to start talking
it was over the indian ocean it was some
crazy [ __ ] you know
so world's most polluted cities china
china india india india and china
yeah indian yeah is there la even in the
top well we're not no
no what no the united states is not even
oh my god
no bangladesh we've been very clean for
a very long time oh my god we're not
even no
it's all china yeah yeah why are they
talking all this [ __ ] to us because
because
they it doesn't mean the narrative here
we have to you know what they do they
give you a really low flush toilet so
you have to flush the toilet twice or
three times and and you use more water
do you you know when they have the one
button or the two so if you take a [ __ ]
yeah yeah i always had the two
european union and the united states are
not the problem yeah it's like you can
keep doing this we've added it makes us
feel good but it's just like uh it's
kind of like the mask in l.a like i know
in 1985
1886 87 88 when you had a tree that came
from indonesia for lumber for timber
there was all kinds of rules if you
wanted to have it come in the united
states you had to have all kinds of
certificates make sure it wasn't a
certain
age it wasn't from a certain region it's
not the chinese back then when i went to
indonesia the chinese were the ones
coming in and just
decimating the forest what they would do
is they'd pay off the officials
and by the way if you were environmental
if you were actually an environmentalist
you could get killed if you were in the
way of those bulldozers they were like
it's not going to happen we got people
you just accidentally died huggers
yeah chin ran over a guy killed it was
his fault though he was his father he
killed a gun i didn't kill him when he
was trying he made a lot of money
snapped his leg or something like that
his foot he can't walk normal anymore
that's [ __ ] up but he makes so much
money now it's like yeah he sued the
company hank so really and they put
money they put our story into their
handbook too
oh really yeah like safety
i kept handbook
job because it was his fault she was
driving a forklift and the guy jumped in
front of me in the bottom he was in the
bottom i was on the very top you can't
see so it wasn't even your fault no no
they have to warn you hey i'm down here
so then i'll stop and they can walk
around
wait so he had to warn you
it was he sued him but i saw him he sued
the company not chin chin got fired
though no i no i kept my job the guy
left but yeah because if it was my fault
they would fire me
how long did you stay chin
for another like years guy left he
didn't need that shitty job anymore
because he sued and what he i like i
said before i think he did it on purpose
he would walk underneath forklifts to
have something happen to him
but i'm saying
why wouldn't it be his fault if he was
the one that's supposed to say no it
wasn't his fault
that's a distinct possibility what when
you're so miserable at your job yes
and i know people that know him i'm not
saying that happened for sure but that's
what i think that's it
that's a lot of people say it don't chat
on that's online either no
it's in the handbook dude okay yeah it
didn't but the traumatic thing for me
was when he took off his shoe and i saw
like blood come out of it that was like
my friend my friend
a very heavy woman
your friends in the airport have you
heard my buddy my buddy bob there's a
very heavy woman
and she um got
run over her foot got run over by a her
foot two car all those cars well the car
hit her here and she was a very heavy
woman and she fell down and my buddy
helped her up and her foot came off
but
like there it was attached to the tendon
but the foot just went blue and it came
off and she went oh and he goes don't
look at your foot don't look at your
foot look right here look here i got you
i got you and he held her foot in place
and he [ __ ] he's very strong picked
she was very heavy picked her up her
husband was like a little guy who was
like whoa
and my buddy's all macho and he just
picked her up and put her in there and
held her foot in place because the
husband fainted he couldn't take it he's
sorry but he fainted damn that's crazy
so now my buddy's holding them so now
that's crazy yeah watch it can i ask you
a question yeah
do we believe her foot came off [ __ ]
i do believe ryan
no no hey hold on hey yeah do you
believe her entire foot camp i think
what happened was the foot broke the
bone broke probably broke and the full
sprite made it to the side that's fair
yeah severed off though no no it didn't
come off it was stuck it stuck with the
tendon stayed the tendon held it on but
the foot went blue flopped off so he's
holding it in place here's why i believe
him
because he was living with me at the
time and he didn't have a lot of money
and the guy had a lot of money and the
guy said i'd like to give you some money
oh because he picked that big [ __ ] yes
and then my he was turned out to be a
big wealthy uh real estate guy sure and
my buddy um didn't take the money my
buddy goes don't worry about it and he
needed the money and i was like you're a
[ __ ] man dude yeah he goes actually
how much do you want to give you you
know because i don't know i mean you
know would you say he's the man or is he
stupid because he's broke i think he
felt awkward about it i thought he was
like i don't know what threat
he's like what do you want me to i mean
he goes yeah what do i ask for what are
you gonna give me a hundred grand i mean
don't give me you know what i'm saying
it's like it was so it was weird yeah
but i remember him just kind of going
it was like don't i don't know man
what was the guy like how much do you
want that makes it happen the guy was
just that's awkward yeah the guy just
don't ask me a little guy and he was you
know he had a big wife he just cut and
counted out how much you want also he
fainted yeah
poor guy that's like also you got there
you're with your wife your wife's way
bigger and you faint when her foot comes
off you know
he's trying to hold the guy's head oh
this is a [ __ ] disaster
all right chin's not buying the store
i like that possible
well i think his foot her foot came off
she rolled her ankle
no no i think that i think it broke her
i bet it broke and her foot was like
[ __ ] that's what i mean it was floppy
i don't say come off though
yeah so there is a video of skydivers
jumping out of the plane while the plane
stalls so as they're falling the plane
is also going towards the bottom and
faster than them yeah it's moving faster
than them fortunately no one gets hurt
but two skydivers get very close to the
plane you know the idea of it yeah after
these ads
so many ads
okay
it's a very long ad too
let me refresh and see if this pops up
the rock is so good
yeah
cricket still thing yeah i mean
i think t-mobile bought them
the the other problem is there was a guy
who was underneath the guy they were
falling and the guy pulled a chute and
as he pulled the shoe he came up and the
other guy came and took his legs off he
hit it hit his legs his legs right up
and he died because he was coming to
terminal velocity so you pull your shoot
up you come up oh you forgot that there
was somebody skydiving down
and hit you damn not a good time holy
[ __ ] it says your video begins in one
second let's see
here we are
big moments for skydivers video shows
16 000
i did it once in college i was like i
gotta j when you're looking down and you
got and he goes skydive and i was on a
slack chord i wasn't you had a guy on
your back no i was on a slack chord so
you jump and and it pulls out okay
still scary as [ __ ] is anyone else down
here no i kind of want to yeah we can't
do it our boy andy
kept saying come he's got the squirrel
suit records and he's like navy seal i
was like
no that's ever happening what else you
got jen
would you ever ever go bungee jumping
absolutely not for what maybe there's a
way i'm not saying i don't know i don't
think we can
i've seen big [ __ ] do it i'm not
doing it do you see the lady and i think
it's
somewhere in the middle east she jumps
and someone forgot to attach the corded
thing
it was on world star and i was like yeah
i gotta see this i clicked on it well
she's like hey everyone and the guy's
like just and she's like eager to go
he's like just hold on hold on and he
straps thing gives a thumbs up but
someone
did it so it's just like
and you're like okay let's go and pull
the rope and just slap
she just dies yep wait she jumped i
started my morning with that no no
there's a video of it oh yeah wait she
jumped like it's like a tall building oh
and then you're this was boying and back
up but just the bungee cord yeah the
bunch cord went got it well i'm not
working today oh today's my day off no
one told you i'm not gonna
pull her back god damn it oh and her her
family is waiting
and
the screams like you've never heard
before it's not the way you want to
start your monday morning not the way
you want to start your monday literally
just like yeah and they're all three two
one she's all yay
you can't and you can't i went now
here's the [ __ ] up part about life
here's the [ __ ] up part
i need to see it
and i i know go to world championship
and i don't want to see it because i i
want to be respectful and i don't like
did you ever watch the daniel pearl
beheading i never watched that i lost
for four days i won't watch that i saw
that too i won't watch that that was
like back in the day right it's a
um it's g
i won't watch those kinds of things well
there it is yeah yep horrible mom i
don't know honestly i don't want to
watch no no i'm talking about that [ __ ]
i don't want to watch it i feel bad no
no i don't want to watch it yeah i feel
bad i feel bad for the family and i
don't want to be i don't want to be
disrespectful i can't believe that
you're the one that said i want to watch
it i didn't want to i was describing it
i'll watch it on my own no but don't
it'll ruin your day
first of all i can't believe they
actually put that video up
it's world star dude she's a mom with
the family there god damn it oh and it's
they're like russian or something
they're like counting down oh that's not
english [ __ ] dying that way it's like
there are other ways at least at least
you're not scared you know at least at
least you you know yeah like i guess
you're like whoa
yeah
yeah that's it it's just lights out
hopefully it's like remembering the
sopranos the way they ended it where
it's just like dark lights out you know
just pulled the plug well your body just
what they say i don't know who said this
because they've never died before but so
your body just releases all the dopamine
endorphins yeah so you like go into this
different world well they they say when
you and then that shuts off
when they with the guillotine when they
would cut your head off they would hold
the head up and sometimes people would
be mouthing prayers
so the idea okay the idea is is your
brain your brain can live without oxygen
for a little while so the idea would be
can you steal your body
and what does that do to you can't
rattle snakes still bite you if with
multiple hearts
yeah
yeah that's science dude what else you
got
yeah you don't want to look at that
video
if you guys are looking for it if you're
listening to me it's on worldstar just
type in bungee jump it's the first video
uh jeff bezos saw the video of his
girlfriend swooning over leonardo
dicaprio and he decided to respond with
a photo
leo come on over here i want to show you
something
that's great good for him bodied up too
by the way he's bodied up yeah he's on
trt mr trt i got to get on trt it could
be you dude
how old is bases same as
57 damn he's from new mexico
oh he's in january dude isn't that where
uh just like bill gates is from too he
has 200 beers
he worked on uh he worked on ran on a
ranch when he was a kid
especially in the summer times
went to princeton
he's a smart dude
what a sketching
there we go
so
a band called water parks i've never
heard of them before but
yep water parks
um apparently they have a pretty uh good
following and one of their fans decided
to get a tattoo of their album name but
the tattoo artist actually wrote it
wrong and this tick tock went viral the
front man of the band saw this tattoo
mistake and said you know what i'm gonna
do you solid he changed the album name
to the mistake so but all the mistake
was they added two ins yeah so see you
in in the future yeah it's supposed to
be see you in the future by his tattoo
artist but see you in
in the future
but yeah it's a good story now because
they changed it for him oh that's dope
yeah that's such a tight move see you in
in the future
and and the future how my artist will
see you in the future
that's actually works see you in at
least it wasn't like two well
the
wrong they just
it was grammatically wrong yeah
that's dope the band did that though
yeah
have you heard of the band water parks
pop punk
i i i have to say i see a lot of really
bad tattoos on people and i i do judge
them like i'll just see like
there's certain people
what happened oh doggie growling
he's probably hungry no he heard the
door open wow protection good guard dog
yeah the dog's fat you see that you see
that dog he's chopped up a little mowgli
you ain't seen my quirky though he's
chubby he's chubby i like him chubby
yeah they don't live long but that's
fine
he's so cute
look at him he's a cute dog though there
he is
that's a bummer but he looks friendly
he's like a good belly rub
tiny had big body huh
he's like a [ __ ] uh body of looking
eat the seal
kind of he looks like something from
star wars and he walked in and he walked
he walked yeah i like that nose on him
won't say that much i don't like to brag
i don't like to brag about this but two
times in the past month i've had i've
been walking down the path
i've had dogs come up to me and say hi
and the owners have said
he never does that
and i was like
i'm the dog i just have i just have a
purity to me man what happened to that
dog whisperer guy
he still does shows i think yeah he's
still he's still doing [ __ ] i love when
he got attacked by that uh golden
retriever
oh yeah yeah
sometimes when you're around problem
dogs yeah some dogs are crazy
sometimes aren't all there that's all
he's still doing the goddamn yeah he's
still doing he's he's really good at
that [ __ ] man
one hour ago
in this video i helped harry a
seven-year-old basset hound who can't
keep out of trouble
there are three phases of me in a dog
brian and you know this eye contact
getting close sniffing each other which
one does harry struggle with let's find
out well i've seen them
care i do not care oh does the dog bite
him because he was trying to bite the
beagle no no this is some [ __ ] i
don't know yeah i don't know he knows
his dog's though boy he knows that
[ __ ] balls deep in dogs yes he
is
what else you got jen
let's go with um
do you know grant hill the anime player
no she just had her first fight right
yeah oh wow amateur fight and he wrote
this post about it four days later i'm
still on my daughter milo's performance
the first amateur mma fight she was
focused composed which her mother and i
were not before and during the fight
aggressively
and clearly not afraid of the moments i
thought to god so this is her she's the
one the 19.
i think she was 19 yet yeah
and she's the one in the background in
the black
okay see the other girl is white though
i can't tell
now she's probably got dad's athleticism
i couldn't tell you that
yeah thanks
i got you
anyway she gets her hair
she took her down mm-hmm
suck stamp take that shin guards oh she
got her back yeah so she choked her out
little beast that's cool man yeah
wow
dad's grand hill
oh yeah
and
do you recognize who this person is um
hold on
that is a problem
there's a photoshop of chin's head on
wait a minute basically yeah you guys
have the same face
[Laughter]
that just means you're a good-looking
guy yeah that's what i'm saying
so that was a picture of her four years
ago when she was on jessica
that's just simpson right there she's
sober now though
that was jessica simpson what go back i
just i worked with her i know you say
that i don't know i don't even recognize
her but she was so devastatingly no
she's still she's hot she's bad she's
back so that was just how that's her
carbs alcohol after four years she
posted this picture showing her when she
wasn't sober so now this is how she's
turning it is her man like hold up let
me get this picture oh wow that's her
nose she's amazing she's so bad good
yeah that's right she has them sweaters
puppies for days yeah yes she does and
her husband played pro football he's a
backpacker she used to be with nick
lachey oh yeah they had that show on mtv
it was fun she asked if chickens
yeah
yeah
and he was just like oh my god he's like
what yeah he was like what the [ __ ]
frustrating divorce like shortly after
how old are you
good question
yes she is she was an employee of the
month she looks so hot in that movie oh
i love that look how big she is in that
picture where she's 40 oh here 41.
that's a 41. yeah yeah she's not that
old
god but see that picture doesn't look as
crazy as this one this one's just her
face looks different you know i think
she she looks worse than the other ones
yeah johnny knoxville
yeah after um after nick lachey or
something
dude yeah that duke's hazard oh really
oh she was really hot in there too
yeah she's gorgeous man gorgeous she's
always really good
she would hold it
down uh this is a little bit older
but all these kids at the villanova
game having like an elevated court so
all these kids just kept falling down
when was that elevated corpus taking
they were trying to rush this yeah
why are they all eating [ __ ] because it
elevated court happening i don't
understand what's happening well because
the court is uh yeah it's a little
higher and they don't think it's a step
so they think you just go straight to
the court but there's a statement yeah
they say i won't get kept
[Music]
and this is just confirmation that
there's going to be a season two yeah
yeah i think it was a company that had
set up like uh different squid games
entire i don't even know if they were
sending out products i think they were
just scamming people
because it never got sent out dude you
get your money back
i'm gonna do i'll make one i have a
thick boy yeah maybe
yeah but sweet games what what what
about if i started on there i was
thinking about what if i start dressing
like the old school gangsters where i'm
in track suits like velour tracks
you could pull that off bring that up
bring up the old school gangsters like
like well they're doing it's a it's a
movement now over in europe they do it
yeah yeah you can get them they're sick
looking we thought about dom remember
jay was trying to get us all in one i
don't know where we were yeah
maybe i'll start with that
yeah
yeah brian you could totally pull that
basically you
fellas what the [ __ ] right with that
with that guinea underneath what what is
that
that could be cool it does look pretty
cool like this guy right here the new
ones yeah right there right yeah yeah
that's literally how they dress those
mobsters
what's going on in this i don't know if
they dress like that today but go down
chin you see the guy in the the printed
one keep going down
keep going see that guy walking right
there right there that's what's popping
right now that's uh what's it called
that's called pharaoh but
what's the movie
uh
the gentleman yeah yeah i would wear
that you look
cool in that hold right i'd like to know
and he's saying a little
yeah what about adidas this right here
will be good adidas track suit like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can find that
you can ride kenny adidas right now and
get a track suit yeah
comfy
or something
i don't remember what happened to them
outside the stoop oh think we're going
to make some track suits yeah like that
right there no uh that's not for us i
would i would do those games people
won't wear them
i mean i'm sure we'd sell a few but not
like it's not that's not what kids would
wear i i don't think so
i'm surprised i do
well with squid games i feel like people
would yeah me too you know
i just don't know how i feel about the
next season without the cast from season
one
well i don't think so well the main
characters involved the main character
everyone else say the hot chicks out
though i know
have we heard from makers how many of
those actors
uh they were actually in la recently
they were actually doing anything like
well the they just made the sopranos the
movie joey diaz is in they're all in it
right
oh
i don't know i mean they're blowing up
their at least their social media is
blowing up you know that you know
joffrey from game of thrones quit acting
yeah i think he's trying to be a doctor
now
he wants to be a doctor and also his
character was so evil he was getting
typecast he's like oh [ __ ] this yeah
yeah
smart
this guy mm-hmm he's i mean he's so good
hideous characters of all time man he
played it well he oh he killed that role
yeah and people are so stupid i'm sure
on the street he was getting [ __ ] all
the time and stuff yeah because lena
heathy said the same thing about playing
cersei that people would treat her
poorly in real life because of how well
she played herself i would about that's
her in real life she's so hot i'd say my
queen and get down one leg
remember her in in 300. oh yeah oh when
she's gorgeous
i'm not your king
[ __ ] up ah hot
i'm not your king this is not gonna be
nice keep your mouth open
what else you got jen
that kid just quit
you know the kid from willy wonka and
chocolate factory he that's the only
movie he ever did and went oh this sucks
i'm not doing this anymore
he did that one movie the og one oh yeah
the the good i mean the real one the the
johnny depp one i love johnny but that's
timothy chalamet is going to be the new
willy wonka now who
uh timothy shalom who's that he's the uh
current heartthrob the guy from doom the
kid from dude yeah yeah uh call me by
your name super feminine oh he was
dating uh lilly depp for a while god is
he feminist
he's like the current teen heartthrob
he's gonna be the next willy wonka yeah
they're doing a willy wonka origin story
oh i like that he's really really cool
he did a movie i forgot what it was
called with um
the guy from the office michael scott
not michael oh steve carl
there we go uh
about addiction so [ __ ] good oh i in
the uh i've seen it mm-hmm and uh yeah i
know what you're talking about he's a
very uh good actor great actor
is he english uh no he's from new york
very androgynous yeah
very sketchy
very
let's go with
uh
this one so this is
hold on you had something which one oh
never mind i got a bunch but i'm just
seeing what's best
oh this one i thought was pretty crazy
this is like a youth basketball game
and uh [ __ ] this girl up i've seen this
you saw this okay i'll just play it for
you real quick she lights her up watches
so it's when they're going the other way
yes so this girl gets the ball she tries
to take a three-pointer
this girl she falls on that girl
and then watch
[Applause]
and if you here in the background you
kind of though the mother of the girl
that got hit said that the mother of
that girl that hit her
she was so she's like you got to hit her
for doing that for messing up so she she
kind of did this like put her hand out i
don't think it punched her
oh yeah punch her with her forearms
knocked her down she's definitely better
yeah
hey man it looks like glasses
you don't see this it is a horrible
video it's definitely a blurry video
yeah i can't tell what's going on she
hits her and then she she's swinging so
hard her arm like almost
watch her right here are you [ __ ] me
boom oh jesus you guys know yeah it's
like neck and chin area
tell me [ __ ] i saw it now it's a
blurry video though what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was that was [ __ ]
yeah so
though to be fair what do you say you
have bad eyes yeah he has bad eyes man
i'm fine you need glasses i'm fine he
has glasses glasses do you have glasses
i'm fine he has them i i remember him
wearing it i don't wear him a lot
[ __ ] supposed to wear him at night
you always want to beat them driving and
[ __ ]
oh i'm fighting the dad he's like
yeah he's like i had nothing to do i'm
like i know but i can't beat her up you
got to take this yeah you gotta yeah i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do what your daughter
did to my daughter because her daughter
said she her mom said to the daughter
you got to hit her yeah you got to hit
her that dad's getting beat up yeah she
didn't mean like that
i don't think she actually meant like
punch her in the face yeah
i don't know she said the girl and the
mom showed absolutely no remorse and
offered so what happens that girl she
gets suspended so the mom's asking that
she gets um they both have her on the
team yeah also big girl man she's very
very great yeah that was a hard hit too
man
she came with a
dude that was a heart that's like a
street fight dude hit yeah just
clothesline yeah like bam yeah
we can't have that also it's orange
county basketball take it easy girl
take it easy it's built like big baby
yeah here's the
trailer for the seated
i can't wait is this god timothy
yeah dude he looks badass
he's your age brian
yeah
let me say it now watch him
taylor shared in the best is this not
the music from our trailer when you were
a cowboy as an indian pretty much buddy
sam elliott
love him
faith hill him and his wife are in it
faint hills yeah
billy bob thorne is that him
i'll watch it that's john dutton's great
grandpa
i think that's the thing that's that
that looks dope almost 20 years after
the civil war wow it looks good yeah
mm-hmm
it looks real dope
i don't know what else i have it oh yeah
uh this is a real quick one i didn't
know about this but i guess it's a
mcdonald's hack
i'll just play it for you
let me refresh
mcdonald's hack number 17 don't ever
order hot cakes did you know that hot
cakes are 3.69 hold on first off that's
not the one
i think it's this one mcdonald's hack
number 25 the budget breakfast the
sausage mcmuffin and sausage biscuit are
both 1.19 but what are they missing one
egg what's the cheapest thing you can
ever buy ever one egg how much is a
sausage mix muffin with one egg 3.79
what it costs two dollars and sixty
cents to add one egg i can get a dozen
at publix for two dollars and you're
gonna go home and make
i have no idea it's not much it's like
you like steak
go home and cook your own steak
so you're saying order the folded egg on
the side and make
the
like instagram facebook stopped working
on the same day i think it was when she
said
she's saying that she's worried that the
metaverse that mark zuckerberg is doing
is going to make us even they're going
to even collect more information and
more data from us so it's going to be
dangerous what i was saying
that's why
you think of course it will
whole new set of dangers yeah no [ __ ]
yeah you'll be in the metaverse yeah
yep
but it's interesting they're going to
hire 10 000 engineers to work on video
games when they haven't actually gotten
safety right on their main product
unless he wants to prioritize the safety
and platform you should step aside let
someone else focus on that but i think
we're headed towards that direction
regardless yeah i was gonna say like
you're not stopping he's not
yeah like what are we going to do i mean
i guess read the book of revelation we
just have to adjust i can repent right
now i don't
what the [ __ ] are we going to do like
this it's so scary to think about what
technology is can i still resist
electric cars huh i'm still resistant to
electric cars i know you eat them i hate
them i'm mowgli in california
i have oh yeah i rented them you just
don't you just like that they're just
lame dude you like the engine yeah i
like cars i don't like go carts but it's
so fast
that's not easy yeah you like that feel
you like the feel of the engine though
you just i don't like your electric cars
that's what happens you're gonna have to
that's the bummer you can take when
they're from steam to gas i'm sure
there's some steam guys what the [ __ ] is
now when we see you uh when we see in
dallas tomorrow daddy is it gonna be
metaverse or is it gonna be live
live live we don't have metaverse yet no
no metaverse yet but i like where your
head's at thank you but please don't
bring goggles because this is not
metaphorical no you got it you can wear
goggles you got to see this raw face raw
face raw face i'm going full flesh face
november 11th flesh face
addison fresh face
that's this thursday friday saturday
shooting the special friday and saturday
that's the taping and then november 27th
uh everett washington everett theater
it's haunted i don't care it's three
minutes outside seattle so we'll see you
guys one night only everett washed in
theater uh and then december 30th
through january 1st bring in the new
year's 2022 with your thick friends here
by thick i mean me and chappelle at
dania florida which is fort lauderdale
dania uh improv right in fort lauderdale
basically come on come on out come on oh
and for uh dallas you can only get it in
person at the taping of the special we
have a built thick boy collab uh dallas
shirts for you bro whisper shirts
this weekend naples florida november 11
twelve thirteen fourteen eighteen on a
sunday just talked to my boy you all set
up yeah all set up you already has wine
free and whiskey's the best i'm telling
you i can't wait you guys that foods
naples florida i'm gonna be there i'll
be eating at that restaurant uh with
everybody every night you don't know the
name
november 19th and 20th orlando florida
i'll be there at the improv and then
december 17th through the 19th kansas
city missouri i'll be in uh at the
kansas city improv
um and by the way december 15th we're
doing a show the three of us are doing a
show oh [ __ ] yeah oxnard california one
night only one night shows one on monday
night december 15th we'll give you
details as we get them it's gonna be a
good it'll be fun i think it's already
on sale yeah they will be that's gonna
be a fun night
real soon so we're excited and then uh
november 17th next week i'll be at
tacoma comedy club and then the
following night november 18th i'll be at
spokane comedy club and then december
1st i'll be at san jose improv oh and
next week fine kid will come out on
tuesday because brian's not here on
monday so yeah heads up all right love
you bye dallas see you this week